a major upgrade to the i-15 tropicana
interchange is officially getting
started that's right the transportation
secretary joined the governor steve
sislak at allegiance stadium today to
launch the project joe moeller was
present he shows us how this could
impact your drive
with the legion stadium now open and
bringing traffic to the area ndot says
it is time to replace the 60 year old
i-15 tropicana interchange this project
will cost millions of dollars and takes
several years to complete
the project includes an expansion of
tropicana a new bridge over the freeway
a new flyover exit from the 15 to
eastbound tropicana and a new alignment
for dean martin for traffic to smoothly
flow under tropicana crews begin work
tonight and it will go through 2024
governor syslack and secretary buda
judge talked about the need in this area
here we are in a place that is
experiencing such extraordinary growth
in jobs in population and economic
activity which brings a lot of
challenges to support that growth with
adequate infrastructure to keep it going
the cost of the project 305 million
dollars 50 million of that is coming
from a department of transportation
grant about 4 600 jobs will be connected
to the project over its duration it's a
struggle getting out on the weekends
rachel mcdermott works at nearby gaming
and entertainment touch technology she
thinks this could help i think it's
going to really help alleviate traffic i
think that after events it will
definitely make people getting home a
lot easier a lot safer too so how much
of a traffic problem will this cause on
the roads a representative from ndot
says the major closures that will impact
traffic won't be taking place until
early 2023 and that includes some short
temporary closures of the 15. reporting
near the strip joe muller live local now